let's talk about the um
the political manipulation of
information let's call it that this
morning when i was reading about the
news and uh just going over general
fact-checking and stuff i came across uh
i'm i was fairly certain i was reading
somewhere on wikipedia
that the taliban was estimated in 2017
to have 200 000 soldiers which is a
massive number and that means there was
a massive increase in the size of the
taliban during the obama biden
administration specifically because
their numbers were substantially lower
around 2008 or so so they went up from
like you know eighteen thousand to fifty
thousand to two hundred thousand by 2017
well that would imply that donald trump
before he came in office
inherited this co inherited this
conflict in afghanistan that was
untenable 200 000 taliban that's a crazy
number
well we were doing research for this uh
for for this show and i was like i want
to pull that up and talk about that
that's really interesting see like who's
really at fault here i mean biden's
president now but he was vice president
you know for for eight years when this
problem was happening so i google
searched here's what you find when you
google search taliban size in 2017. it
says in 2017 the taliban was estimated
to have 200 000 troops and that's the
wikipedia entry for the taliban however
if you actually go that entry has been
removed and they've changed i'll just go
right in they've changed the year check
this out to 2021 now look at that that's
really interesting because
you know why why those years and why
remove that source and then say 200 000
in 2021 well in my opinion
it changes responsibility
if you're saying that in 2014 there were
60 000 uh taliban
you're basically implying that under
donald trump the taliban massively grew
in size yet when you google search it it
said 2017. so which is it honestly i
don't know for sure
the sources have changed and i'll tell
you this
everybody is going to try and use that
to point the blame at the other side but
i do think it's fair to say
obama biden had eight years of this
trump came in put in a deal to shut it
down i'm glad it's finally over i can
say that i don't know if you guys what
your thoughts are on the numbers yeah i
i don't uh i don't know who who keeps
count on the taliban count uh on taliban
numbers if it's intelligence community
they were saying a couple of days ago
that
kabul can hold the taliban push for 90
days and it held like for 90 minutes 90
hours
so
isn't it crazy to think that they have
two hundred thousand i'm wondering if
they change the way that they measure
who's in the taliban or not like they do
with the census
like how like obama did when he started
killing civilians right like it could be
any non-american yeah like i saw i saw a
tweet i think um
i forgot who it was he said that any red
tape
any refugee red tape from afghanistan
needs to be removed and we need to
welcome in uh you know refugees
so i wrote what's the process for the
u.s to protect against former taliban
members who will then claim their
refugees it's not like the u.s has a
database database of exactly everyone
who is part of the tolerance so i think
a lot of these numbers whether they're
more or less i think it's just guesses
estimates which
if it's from intelligence community it's
potentially uh flawed as we have seen
many things
uh that they estimate about afghanistan
uh being totally flawed so the source
for the wikipedia uh that says 200 000
is in january now here's the funny thing
al jazeera the taliban explained they
say on the 25th of july 2021 and updated
on august 15th
they mentioned let's scroll right down
the group is believed to have 85 000
full-time fighters across the country
and exert control over more than half
the country's roughly 400 districts why
isn't this article which is newer used
as the source on wikipedia why was the
data changed it's good propaganda baby
that's a lot of taliban makes us look
like the good guys isn't it crazy to
think that we're in an information i'm
not going to say one is writer i'm sure
someone will make their argument they'll
be like oh well that was an official
report you know from you know a military
contractor or from the government this
is al jazeera and then someone could
argue well al jazeera's got resources in
the region they certainly have better
access to the information and they're
going to know better everyone's going to
argue but i'll tell you this we are we
are constantly in the middle of
propagandistic warfare it is
it's a horrible reality of of the world
we live in
you know we we used to have tv
commercials now it's constantly they're
they're changing history you know the
news breaks it looks bad for obama so
they had four years hey the estimate two
hundred thousand they removed the 2017
number and now it seems like trump
who is looking at afghanistan as a
project in the in the through the
perspective of whether it's a bomb or
not i think the average person who
follows the news
zooms out for a moment says you know
what it's 20 years there's been many
presidents and even biden you know biden
didn't come in as someone saving today
he was a senator for i don't know how
many years that afghanistan was going on
and then he was vice president so he
wasn't an onlooker
he was there for most of the time so i
think
the typical person who follows the news
a little bit thinks of afghanistan as a
as a total mess all around this party
that party it doesn't matter it's like
it's a mess and i think people are left
scratching their heads okay we had their
only two and a half thousand uh soldiers
there for a while now
and the piece held so what happened now
that everything went to hell in the
handbasket
i think i think just from a practical
perspective not necessarily political
people would want to want to wonder that
rather than exactly when it went up or
down might be it was costing us 40
billion a year uh recently up to now
like a couple trillion since we went in
2 trillion i think so maybe it's just
like bankrupt times because of covid so
the economy's not doing too got to cut
costs
i gotta say i really love uh the the
meme posts where it's like uh
the school children in afghanistan and
and all of these establishment dems are
like
these poor school children now can't go
to school and the girls are running home
and then someone comments none of them
are wearing masks
like where's the priority for
afghanistan for these kids or whatever
not that i think that's actually the
main priority yeah you wanna use an
interesting number um
a couple of months ago when people
debated handing out another two thousand
dollars in stimulus
the democrats wanted uh
two thousand dollars per family or
something and mitch mcconnell was
willing to give only um
six hundred dollars this was a big fight
before the georgia runoffs
if you take 40 billion dollars
and you give it hand it out to americans
1400 more you can actually give it to 28
million
american households you can give this 40
billion dollars so
mitch mcconnell was willing to sign off
on all these big
military spending bills every year
and this is just uh 40 billion for
afghanistan
and he wasn't willing to spend money
there it's just interesting uh how
people decide the priorities of politics
yeah and it's interesting i think i
think the important thing to point out
is
the establishment republicans and
democrats were all in on this it was you
know like i think it's silly to play
these games you've got people saying
blame trump on twitter it's virally
trending you've got people saying you
know biden's crisis or whatever i do
think it's fair to say you like biden's
the president you know i i we don't know
what trump would have
what would have happened we can
speculate i certainly think there would
have been problems he would have been
criticized but i think you look at what
he did with like sulaimani and he would
have been
you know he could have been dropping
bombs on on the taliban yeah but the
question is in a year or two from now um
how would people view
the u.s moving on from afghanistan will
they
view it as uh will they remember the the
the few days of crisis now or will they
say oh you know what we were there for
20 years now we're gone and everything
is good i think it's going to be real
negative i think it's going to be a a
smear on the bind administration in a
very very bad way for him i think it's
going to be used by republicans
relentlessly but i do think a lot of
regular people are going to say
both parties were involved both parties
take responsibility to be fair though i
think the trump uh base and trump
himself are only you know uh
they're not really republicans in the in
the traditional sense you know trump was
an insurgent candidate the republicans
didn't like him they didn't like him
when he was president and even now
you've got the established republicans
you've got the populist republicans
making up a smaller uh batch of those
running in 2022.
ultimately i think
we can look back to 2000's we can look
back to all the mistakes that were made
i think in the end a lot of people are
just going to say i'm glad it's over
with but we're going to see a lot of
news about what's what's going to be
happening in afghanistan that's true
after this it's going to be
you know women are already wearing
burqas like literally a day later and
you see all the men even you even have
the reporters you know that uh closer
award from cnn she's wearing the burka
now she she is saying if the meme isn't
correct that she made this dramatic
change she always wore a headscarf but
now she's wearing the more you know
she's so yeah she wrote she's she's
wearing something more and as i wrote on
twitter you know it's interesting how
some reporters i'm not saying she
specifically they are
you know they have the
self-proclaimed guts to go after the
pro-religious states here in the us but
when they're overseas they they respect
religion or whatever you know if you
want to respect religion
on whichever level it is then you know
you should do that do that at home too
and not pile on to indiana or texas or
what have you
i think in the coming months
we are going to see some really awful
imagery out of afghanistan uh i think
a lot of people in the establishment are
going to try and use it to justify why
we should have stayed why we shouldn't
have withdrawn and i think a lot of
people i think it's going to actually i
take that back i take that back what i
want to say is i think there's going to
be news available but i wonder if the
media is actually going to show it
because it will reflect extremely poorly
on joe biden whether whether you believe
it's his fault or not he's the president
and people are going to say the biden
administration and afghanistan i didn't
i think it's going to be really bad for
him uh you know what we don't have is a
lot of video of the war itself which we
had in vietnam was all the video on the
ground with the troops dudes getting
their legs blown apart guys you know
screaming for their mother and falling
down on punji sticks you know the terror
the horror and and in in afghanistan we
didn't get to see it they didn't they
opted out so we get the doors getting
kicked in little kids getting mowed down
we don't get to see that stuff we so now
we now they're going to imaginarize us
with this we just end this i'm sorry tim
no no sorry i was i just wanted to just
address one point you made is that we do
have a lot of images out of afghanistan
we've we've long had that but relative
to vietnam after vietnam they realized
we got to stop putting our media on the
ground with the troops because they're
seeing too much of the horror and we're
not going to get our wars if we or
potemkin rides you know
yeah security first half iraq war they
did a potemkin ride through the desert
with for abc media everything's great
look it out look at look at somebody
then there's also i think i think uh
things were relatively stable in the
last few years in afghanistan in terms
of the u.s u.s uh casualties and so
forth uh yeah we've our tech is more
advanced that's correct so so it it
isn't it isn't the vietnam era but i get
your point yeah yeah we don't see the
americans dying but we also don't see
the the afghani kids getting getting it
either if they're if
if they really wanted to make this
project or whatever they were doing work
you'd have to be there for a hundred
years you would have to
uh raise generations but i i just i i i
won't get finished no no i'm saying i'm
trying to understand i'm
not too you know just to ask a question
the us
figured after world war ii that they
need to stay long-term
in
many of these places i don't think
things were perfect the day after the
war probably there were some casualties
and issues
so from a policy perspective if the us
was able to keep the peace relatively
okay with just a few thousand troops
not even being so active on the ground
what's the problem with that i mean you
still have troops today in germany
obviously not because to keep the peace
there but just it illustrates the point
where for many years um yeah east german
germany and west yeah the berlin wall
came up in in 1960 or the late 1950s it
wasn't right after
world war ii which finished on 45
so obviously any place where things are
so rocky and so destructive it probably
takes many many years to have some sort
of an outside
for a peacekeeping force or something so
i understand people became tired from
afghanistan but
considering that the u.s kept the peace
there now with such a small amount of
troops why jump now
again i'm trying to figure it out it's
economic i think i don't know because it
costs so much money well i think uh a
lot of people uh trump supporters
especially don't want our troops
donald trump gets a big big hand for
this i i have a lot of complaints but he
was adamant about getting us out of iraq
he drew us down and he was on a course
he he drew down the forces and therefore
biden comes in and does what what's the
connection between that and biden's
decision now then what happened bryden
said he thought he that he can't go back
on the deal
yeah because it would just mean the
taliban is massively powerful and we
don't have enough troops to actually
stage combat so we better just get him
out
i mean trump trump laid the uh laid the
groundwork
and you know what a lot of people i'm
not a fan of the us being the world
police i i like the idea that i'll put
it this way when i play civilization i
don't go around conquering nations and
that's how i play i play to to to
strengthen and make the world make life
better for the people of my country the
idea that the u.s could keep just going
spending money in places like
afghanistan to try and build nations
i'm not a fan of that i'm not a fan of
the us having troops in germany for that
matter i mean world war ii has long been
over are we really concerned about
europe can't they provide for their own
defense yeah so in terms of if it if
being in afghanistan was the issue of
being there was mostly a monetary
decision then
what about uh whatever amount of
thousands of troops in korea or in
europe
what's the rationale for that i agree
maybe that we're not building
we're not building land in those other
countries obviously yeah obviously they
were safer there you didn't have uh you
know any troops here and there when you
know going into harm's way they were
just you know training there living
there so i'm not saying it's the same
thing
i'm asking this from both ways on the
one hand if you look in
the the war in in after korea
in the 1950 1953 or you look in europe
after 45 the u.s has troops on the
ground till today
so
why not do it in other places on the
other hand if in terms of cost so if you
went out of afghanistan due to cost then
get out of korea and europe too there's
a big difference uh world war ii you had
after world war ii you had the soviets
obviously we split germany in half and
then you uh and then with the rise of
the soviet union their expansion you had
vietnam and korea the idea there was
stop the expansion of communism i'm not
saying i agree with any of that stuff
but i don't know what would have
happened the idea i suppose to try and
play dev's advocate would be
if you don't stop the spread of
communism and they keep taking more and
more countries eventually it will be
impossible to stop the rise of this this
authoritarian system that murders you
know hundreds of millions
so the u.s says we're going to engage
them in proxy wars and defend you know
korea and vietnam they fail we you know
we failed in vietnam korea is
effectively a you know 60 or whatever
right yeah yeah stalemate and then
eventually the soviet union collapses
anyway so i don't know if the u.s you
could say the u.s succeeded in stopping
the expansion of communism which
ultimately fell but what about
afghanistan has anything to do with
that giant threat
in other words yeah because if it's
because if it's uh if it's a uh a
military threat you know the military
hardware that the us has these days
uh by uh sending in a uh strike team or
or droning something or someone i think
uh it's not the same
it's it's an interesting point after
world war ii they did the liberal
economic order they set up like the
world police from 1946 they though
england united states france decided
we're going to set up a global military
force to prevent world war iii they call
it the liberal economic order that's
where they started building all these
military bases and they set up a world
of limited war and henry kissinger for
instance is a huge proponent but i think
we've eclipsed the age of limited war it
no longer makes sense and it no longer
makes sense to have all our troops in a
centralized spot they're too vulnerable
we we do our things from drones from far
away so so so i think you can cut back
from korea even more and come home from
europe thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to see the full show come back to
this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you